now let's just go back to this time
right because this is my algebraic
definition
I just working out to moduli right I can
do too much you're like I just need to
know what's the real part
what's the imaginary part ok said Zen is
any point I'm saying all of these slides
that that's the longest except for
examples that's you
he said that I'm saying satisfies this
just popped me up here every Z is in the
form X plus iy grant where x and y are
my variables so I just got to pop exerci
Y by definition up into the lockets that
I've been provided the equation of the
blockers so let's go back here this is
gonna be the absolute value of with a
bunch of salt X oops sorry X by Y okay
now what you want to work out the
modulus of a complex number right we
know that the modulus is the square root
of now just watch out right usually we
would say if if Z equals x plus iy right
then mod Z is the square root of we're
using pythagoras are we so this would be
x squared plus y squared yeah that's
fine okay however you can see that same
this is kind of a bit confusing here
because the numbers I'm interested in
I'm not just X plus iy anymore they're X
plus iy and some other stuff in there so
I'm going to suggest to you maybe a
clearer way of saying this is to say
what is it it's the it's the real
component of Z right that's what I'm
really swearing and the why of course is
not just why there's why but that's not
already what I want the imaginary part
however much imaginary stuff is there
that's the whole imaginary component
you can see this is rather more awkward
to write but it's more accurate and it
helps you not get confused here right
because when you look at this yeah I'm
okay well what's the real part luckily
it's just there it's still X but what's
the imaginary part it's more than just
than why isn't it so to make it obvious
I'll say plus I put excuse me and I'll
gather all of the parts which have
imaginary components Bailey what I
factored out y -2 that's the thing that
I'm going to be squaring okay on the
right hand side I've got a few more
terms flying around right how many real
parts do I have on that right-hand side
public some up I bet it cost one other
chuckling brackets to well to group them
as the real component and then I say
well the rest of it must be imaginary
what's left I've got a Y take away one
regular ok so that is now when I try to
work out then I can work out the ones
are solved now I can use this okay so
I'm gonna say by definition this is the
square root of that guy there's the real
part being squared of the imaginary part
being squared and I'm gonna do the same
thing over here right there's the real
part
Square it and there's the imaginary part
square that as well okay I'll give you a
second to cut through the numbers and
work out all the algebra let's get a bit
of head start
by the position of what the position
oh okay I see what you mean right the
reason why I put it in this form is so
that I can know like what's it gonna
look like what's it gonna look like okay
excuse me
however like a very real point to put it
in this - like this double negative form
except you see where it is where's the
point I'm interested in wait you go to
here like okay if you wanted to you
could make it - -1 + I but that you're
just gonna have to expand it back - no
separate out your real imaginary perfect
terms so you gain nothing right so it's
a little bit like I'm you know if I told
you there's the equation of a circle I
said it was something like this
okay so here is the equation of a circle
right I know it's gonna be the equation
of a circle because I can complete the
square of the X terms I've been
completely square the Y terms and I'll
get some number over there on the
right-hand side which is my radius
squared okay
now why do I rearrange that with the
whole completing the square business
okay the only reason why I will do that
is so that I can work out where the
center is right and therefore by
extension the radius okay so it's it's
in order to read the geometric features
to understand the lockers better but if
the question was just okay I know I know
x equals zero I just want to find the Y
under sets of this thing okay I mean I
can rearrange it but why bother I can
just put X equal zero straight to that
guy right there's no advantage it's look
it's not quicker to complete the square
get it into a circle radius four and
then say okay now I'll let X equal zero
I mean you care but why why bother
not to say
it is kind of over we're gonna do it
anyway okay
Sarathi you does that make sense like I
mean there's nothing wrong with doing
this and going ahead and take your right
hand side but I can guarantee you you
still get this add an extra life all
right
how did you go did you get that which
lady took yeah all right let's do shall
we okay it is fine I'm gonna square both
sides to get rid of all square roots and
while I'm at it I'm also gonna expand my
terms you can see I'm expecting
something obviously linear expecting
something video I'm a little bit thrown
off by the fact that I have quadratic
terms in there but that's okay I'm gonna
have the same quadratic term on the left
and right hand side so they ought to
come out in the wash right so let's just
quickly rehearse it
so I'm gonna have x squared plus y
squared minus 4y plus 4 yeah
x squared plus 2 X plus 1 plus y squared
yep that check out okay so as you can
see because I expanded easily Y
Squared's cancel X Squared's cancel what
are you getting left with if I am if I
get if I add to both sides I'll be left
with minus 2y there okay I will subtract
4 from both sides which gives me 2x take
away 2 and then I can divide everything
through which leaves me with this just
like I was expecting okay
so it's great to be able to do this
algebraically and sometimes you must do
it algebraically as you
as you've seen some of these ups before
time well I don't know what that she
mentioned cookies and I will show you
more examples of that but what you can't
think about geometrically is it a
powerful we will say that's exactly what
I was expecting
okay it's really really useful